(piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical age.
Bipedal, naked, large-brained.
Alone the master of fire,
tools, and language.
But still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable,
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our
shared understanding of the past.
Carta brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who
we are and how we got here.
An exploration made possible by
the generosity of humans like you.
(techno music)
- So I'm gonna very
specifically talk about modeling
human evolution remarkably in a dish.
This involves this technology
I talked to you about called
induced pluripotent cells which
I'll go into in some depth.
Now, studying evolutionary dish
has advantages and disadvantages.
Comparison between humans,
What we are really comparing
are these particular cell
types not the full organisms.
But the hope is that, or the belief is
that much of the critical changes
that have occurred, occur in the brain,
and that this transition
point from early brain cells
to mature brain cells is
that period of maturation
within a cell lineage, wherein
much of the magic happens
that will be seen as the known or unknown
differences between humans
and our closest relatives.
And as you'll hear, some common themes
emerging from these
speakers, that these early,
very early events, there real differences
that are accruing in the human species
relative to our common relatives
Now, the advantage of this
approach is that we can obtain
a sematic cells, or skin biopsies.
And now this technology can be done
with pretty much somatic cell.
You can obtain them from many species
in very non interventive manner.
We've been developing
basically a cellular zoo now
for the last eight or 10 years,
where we collect biopsies from species,
a variety of different species,
and I'll be talking to you
about these species from
human, bonobo, chimp, gorilla, and rhesus.
In particular you should
remember that the chimps
and bonobo share a significant
amount of their genome,
and yet the brain size
difference between our brains
and our closest relatives
is really quite striking.
We'll learn more about that.
And other differences are that,
in this last period of seven
billion year when we evolved,
many of the genes, many
diseases that have evolved
appear to be unique to humans.
So along with the acquisition
of the unique features
that it is to be human,
we've also acquired
susceptibility to a variety of diseases,
and so one of the advantages,
or one of the goals
of understanding these cellular
molecular underlining mechanisms
that are in involved in
human species evolution will
tell us about the unique
features of these diseases.
So in this particular case, we've acquired
pluripotent stem cells
from a variety of species.
We take the cultures,
we grow them in dishes,
and treat them exactly the same,
and we use a series of
chemical modifications,
instructural modifications
to change these fibroblasts
into what amounts to
an embryonic stem cell.
And this is called induced pluripotency,
and in the end we have a series of
clonal population of cells
that can grow indefinitely,
and under the right conditions,
these cells can be induced
to differentiate into neurons
of a variety of different types,
and it's this ability to be able to look
at each of the different stages.
So we can look at the early stages of
somatic cells as they are growing.
In a dish as IPS cells,
or as the intermediates
that lead to differentiation
of different cell types.
Now, obviously there are limitations,
and we should be aware of those.
We're examining intrinsic differences
that can be detected in
these individual cells.
There must be a genetic or
an epigenetic event that is
underlying any phenotype or
difference that we can detect.
Culture, when I say there
are cultural differences,
in this case I mean tissue
culture, not advanced culture.
Social experience is something
that's very difficult to,
we're not going to capture that
social, acquired knowledge.
Dietary kinds of events are
difficult to completely capture.
And of course, I'll tell
you a little bit about
our attempts to get In vivo
context by transplantation.
And it's really questioned whether or not
the in vitro relevancy of
phenotypes that we look at,
how well do they transfer?
That takes additional
kinds of experiments.
But what it really comes down to is,
are there differences that are detectable
at the cellular level that are relevant
to the understanding of human origins?
So there are some basic features
that we could look at right away.
We know for example that humans
have 46 and chimps have 48 chromosomes.
That they express certain genes that
identify the most primitive state.
So we can look for those to
make sure that when we do
the conversion they are
retained within a certain fate.
We can test weather or not
these embryonic stem cells
that we get behave equivalently
or not equivalently.
So it's really important
right at the very beginning to
determine weather or not we're
seeing differences or not.
So we can monitor them with a
variety of known differences.
So here's some simple ways in which we can
do this more filogically and genetically.
Determine by carry typing the chromosome
that are inherent in
weather or not there's any
gross differences between them.
Weather or not the cells
grow at the same rate.
Weather or not they
express the same genes.
And in our first attempts
at this, years ago,
we first started by looking
at these immature cells,
these IPS, what they call
induce pluripotency cells,
to see if we can determine
any differences between them,
and we did this by extracting DNA,
and we'd look for the expression of all
the genes that were
expressed in these cells
between all the species
to see weather or not
we could find any fundamental differences
that were apparent at that early stage.
And I won't go through this in any depth,
but we, back several years ago now,
we reported that there were features,
particularly interesting to our lab,
that there are genetic
elements in the brain
that have this capacity for hoping around
or jumping from one location to another.
And these genes were very
differently regulated
in chimps and bonobos relative to humans,
to the extent that humans
had developed a mechanism
by expressing two particular genes
that suppressed the
activity of these lyelms,
so the amount of new elements
or new genetic material
that was added into the germ line
through this particular
vehicle was suppressed
in humans relative to our
closest relative species,
and by virtue of the over
expression of these genes.
We went onto hypothesize
about this and have
continued working on these
early primitive cells;
exploring this roll that
these mobile elements play
in carving and crafting
novel phenotypes within,
not just in humans spices, but
in other organisms as well.
One interesting point that
I like to make is that
these line elements is
increasing insertions
of these pieces of DNA
throughout the genome
add to the genetic
diversity of the offspring,
and we as humans have
suppressed this ability
to add this added element
of diversity which may mean
a decrease in behavioral
diversity as well,
limiting our genetic diversity.
Now this less genetic diversity leads to a
dependence now more in cultural change for
adaptation to changes in the environment.
And we are exploring
this as a hypothesis for
how humans are quite
similar to each other.
So what I'm going to
talk to about today is,
in the next few minutes, is about new work
looking at the next
phase of differentiation
which are these neural progenitor cells,
and then subsequently neurons.
So we've developed a
proto call where we can
generate cells into these very
homogenous neural proenitors cells.
They express very unique and features
that we can compare across spices.
and there are methodologies
now that allow us
to use unbiased methods to measure all the
genetic expression that's
unique to these cells
and compare them with one another.
When we do this across all the
spices that we've looked at
from chimps, bonobos,
gorillas and rhesus vs humans,
we see 2,000 genes that are differentially
expressed at a very, very high level,
and among them when we
look at clusters of genes
that have categories in
common called gene anthology,
we find that about a quarter
of those are genes that are
involved in house cells migrate
within a tissue situation.
So migration, the movement of neurons,
seems to be a feature that stands out.
So we set up an assay system to measure
weather or not we could detect that
genetic difference in a
functional difference.
This is an assay where the cells are
plated on a culture dish
and we make a cut here,
and then we ask who quickly they
can migrate into there situation,
and we can monitor the cells
as they grow into this,
and we can color them, and do this in a
much more high resolution
where we can track each cell
and look at the direction that it goes.
When we do this across
multiple species we find
that humans are much slower
in their migratory pathways,
so by 12, 24 hours this pathway
is fully aggregated
together within migration.
Just as another example, we
can look this in another way.
Looking at migration again
as a feature of these cells,
we can label the chimp cells
in green, sorry, in red,
and the human cells in green,
and then mix them together,
and put them at the bottom of
a dish that has microgrooves
where we can monitor, and has a gradient
where we monitor rate
at which the cells grow.
And this allows us to actually
race our two cells against each other,
and see how can get there faster.
We can track again, so it's
another method of this thing.
So here we have, and it sort of depends
on when the cells get into the groove
and then you can start
monitoring how quickly the move.
So here's a, the green cells
are the human moving along
the groove, these are the
grooves that they're in here,
we're watching this cell move along.
Finally, we get a chimp cell in there,
and the the chimp cell sort
of takes off and moves.
Again, evidence, another way in which
we can begin to monitor these differences.
And when we do thousands of these movies
we see that both chimp and bonobo
are really quite similar in their
rate and direction of trajectory
as compared to the human which
appears to be much slower.
In the final assay here we
did a floating assay of cells
that migrate out from the central core,
and we can measure the core of the cell
and the distance that the migrate,
and without much effort you
can see that the human cells,
while played at the same density,
migrate out over a period
of time at a much slower rate
relative to the other cells.
Now as a final assay
for this migration assay
we took advantage of the
fact we had colored cells,
and we transplanted them into a mouse
that had a dilated immune
system, so it didn't recognize
the species difference between
humans and chimps vs itself,
se we could transplant these cells
directly into the brain various regions,
and monitor the rate in
which they were migrating.
And I should say those of
people that work in this field
know that human cells when implanted
tend to aggregate very closely,
so we weren't really
anticipating a difference,
but it's really quite striking.
When we examine these cells
months after the transplantation,
We see that there is, but
it was noticed, as soon as
several weeks afterwards
that the human cells here,
aggregated around the
side of the injection,
whereas the chimp cells
migrated at a much greater rate,
and we could replicate this,
or we could quantify this
in a very dramatically.
So we know now that human,
with all these assays together,
we can convince ourselves
that there really is this
intrinsic migration
difference which reflected
in the gene differences that
we can see between them.
Now that we can transplant these cells,
we can watch their maturation into cells,
and the sort of morphological changes
that happens a neuron as it matures,
is something that is
really well documented.
And with a wonderful collaboration with
Katerina Semendeferi, we were
able to, and Bianca Restudent,
we were able to monitor
these changes in vivo,
between chimp and human,
and the advantage is that
we're mixing the cells together
and injecting them in the
exact site and can monitor
them as they migrate away,
and then look at them over a period of,
in this case something
like 19, or 19 weeks,
and we're looking at a variety
of morphological features,
and strikingly, what we can do is we can
map each individual cell in brain,
and look how its, how it
morphologically develops.
We can see them over
extended periods of time,
and they're color coded
for us in the Brain,
so we can see what they, how they change.
Here you can see, if we
look at dendretic length
they're pretty much
the same, matching same
at these early stages, and
then humans dramatically
take off about six to eight weeks.
At another time we look at segments,
that's the number of branches they have,
also separates that that period.
And then finally we have
the number of spines,
these are the features on
each on of the dendrites
where connects are coming into the cells.
So we see an accelerated differentiation
of the neural progenitor cells over time.
So as a final piece what we did
is a refunctionale consequence.
So we can measure measure
actually, the electrical activity,
weather or not the fire action
potentials in individual cells.
And in these new devices
called a multi electrator ray,
we can play the cells
and then bring them back
to the ray and monitor their activity,
how they communicate with each
other over a period of time.
So they're resting on the
top of these electrodes,
and we can measure their activity.
This system actually allows us
to monitor a variety of features.
We can measure not just the single spikes,
but we can measure issues like bursting,
weather or not they
fire in bursts or they,
weather or not all mini cells that are
connected to each other
fire at the same time.
So finally in this last
piece of information
I'll give you this final data.
When you read this, here at two weeks,
each one of these is a
channel on which cells exists,
so here's a, the human cell.
We have a few of them, few
cells in there that are active.
But clearly at two weeks
the chimp and the bonobo
are both, many many more cells are active.
Not only that but you're
seeing some synchroning,
meaning that cells are actually
connected to each other.
But by six weeks, here
you have now bursting and
synchronized activity at a much
higher rate than the chimps,
evidencing once again that
there's this early event
where the chimps are, and the
bonobos seem to be maturing
at an accelerated rate
relative to the humans.
And we see this reflective
not just in the physiology,
here the chimps extending
quickly and being bypassed there.
And again we have this window of time.
And the way we're beginning
to think about this,
and I think it's consistent
with many others,
is that in human evolution
there's a developmental delay.
Retardation is not a
really good word, and or,
but has been termed as neotenyen,
and in this case it doesn't fit exactly,
because we're not
looking at the end point,
but it is a developmental delay in humans
in their maturation that's been proposed
as a possible mechanism
that can contributes
to the rise of many human spices specific,
including the increase in brain size,
and emergence of human
specific cognitive traits.
So we and others are interested
in this delay feature,
and how this delay feature
may result in these
morphological and genetic
features that we see,
and we'll be talking
more about the mechanisms
that may control this
sort of delayed event,
which is so important for human evolution.
So in conclusion, I hope
I tried to convince you
that the IPS cell approach is,
we're able to generate
similar type cells in humans,
and in non human primates,
and there's this,
a significant amount of similarity
that underlies their maturation,
but that we also discover
unique features that are,
now this is important, cell intrinsic,
cell autonomous, that
we can detect in vitro.
And this consistent
feature reflexes in the
migration of the cell, the
maturation of the dendrites,
as well as the
electrophysiological activity.
So we think that these
approaches can be used as a model
to steady the dynamic
developmental comparative
differences between humans and primates,
and non human primates, and the difference
is that this has on an
evolutionary perspective.
So as usual we have many people to thank,
the leader of this project,
who's unfortunately
was not able to attend is Carol Marchetto.
Variety of people in my own
lab that have more recently
played a role in various
aspects of the analysis.
Katerina Semendeferi and
Branka have been key players
in this morphological analysis
that they are experts at.
I have a variety of people in our
local Carta group that are important,
and my close colleague El
Sematry who's been with us on
the beginning, right from
the beginnings on this work.
And with that I want to
thank you for your attention.
(applause)
(techno music)